i mean like i remember like there's this
uh there's like the [ __ ]
way to onsen i remember us going there
closes huh yeah we need we need to go
before it might be closed by the time it
comes yeah but like there are some
things which i'm i'm [ __ ] i'm
convinced it's just
we should talk about the onsen actually
before we go into the onsen what do you
mean about the oath onsen which is being
shut down in japan oh yeah should we
talk about that now so yeah
unfortunately uh away to onsen which is
probably the best onsen in tokyo the
first onsen
um is closing down yeah not because it's
not going enough customers not because
of covid uh because of this
situation
where you can't lease land more than a
certain amount because they were
literally renting the land and yeah it's
expired and it's insane right it's just
an amazing beautiful onsen uh in tokyo
bay right yeah in uh in odaiba like is
right opposite the [ __ ] gundam as
well literally right next to the gun so
it's it's it's the perfect day trip
because it's amazing yeah because you go
there you go view the gundam you see a
[ __ ] giant mecca and it's absolutely
incredible and then you just go chill in
an onsen with the boys
this onsen is unlike any other there's
like a whole summer festival area that
is permanently there where you can do a
bunch of summer activities there's
restaurants in the onsen so once you get
through you can scan it with like this
this uh kind of like watch thing lately
yeah that's a rubber band yeah you can
get beer you can get a full meal that's
delicious you can get it's amazing
there's so many different baths there's
an outside bath as well there's a sauna
as well yeah and like there's a salt
bath this it's honestly one of the most
amazing onsens there's like a little
like outside garden area
you can spend all day there because have
you like have you talked about like the
middle area where it's just because the
summer festival yeah this is the summer
festival where you you do everything
that you've seen in every summer
festival anime you literally
there's like an arcade there there's
there's like good ice cream yeah the hot
milk cold milk yes
you can get beers you can have a full
meal like it was amazing and it's a
shame that it's shutting down because i
don't really know any onsen that's just
like like that i'll do it yeah
especially in tokyo is it shutting down
this year it's coming down september
yeah oh [ __ ] i think so uh i want to go
one last time i think by the time this
is airing it's probably gone [ __ ] it's
probably gone by the time this might
but yeah it's an amazing onsen i'm very
sad to see it go yeah
september so what were you saying sorry
yeah so the talking about the onsen area
there so there's this area
we've we've just baked it up right but
there is this area in an onsen right um
where
it's like it's like a little stream that
you can walk through that's meant to
massage your feet
um
there's massaging your feet and then
there's just walking on pebbles
like being in like one of some of the
most pain in your life yeah and calling
that a relaxing experience yeah what
about that is relaxing i can't i can't
take a single step in that stream yes so
so it's like lots of little like [ __ ]
goblins just [ __ ] doing this on the
bottom of your feet like every step and
i'm like this is not it's not relaxing
yeah yeah so so so they they have this
little stream right and it's kind it's
like
people walk on it and it's kind of like
an endurance test right it's not like
you you know you know when [ __ ] like
monks like test their endurance by
walking on coals that's what it felt
like because it is pretty bad because
you have like you have like little
pebbles that are just like soldered into
the ground that just stick out and it's
just like you're meant to walk on it and
it's meant to massage your feet right
and it it hurts so much and the stream
goes on forever yeah it's like it's like
200 meters long yeah it's like it's not
that long but it's pretty long it's
pretty long but then at the end of the
stream there's this little like service
you can do where you can get lots of
little tiny fish to uh oh
yeah this is like the dead skin off your
face this is common in a lot of
countries right so yeah this a lot yeah
yeah
as well but it was actually like so i
tried it for the first time with you
guys yeah um and i i still i i think i
still might have the video of us trying
it for the first time if we ever will
play it they're on my legs
i it's so rare in life that you try
something and you feel a sensation that
you've never felt before in your life
yeah and that was me like feeling like
the hundreds hundreds of little fish
just eating the dead skin it was just
like having hundreds of like mini
electric shocks on your feet yeah and i
remember when i first felt it it felt
like the most uncomfortable thing i'd
ever felt before because i'm just like
what is this sensation i've never felt
this before ever and then uh there's a
there's a service actually i found in
okinawa the last time i went because
like there was another one in like a
mall in okinawa where you know they had
a little fish so i did it because i
think it feels really [ __ ] nice and
then the guy was like oh there's a if
you go down the road there's a service
where you can get you can do that with
your whole body
uh i don't know you can literally
submerge your entire body all the way up
to your neck and just just stand there
and the fish will just eat your whole
there are certain areas no idea
they weren't doing it but i was like
[ __ ] i kind of want to try
there are certain areas of my body that
i'm just like i don't want fish coming
anywhere near this area man
eating the skin off this one no thank
you thank you yeah i'm sure like you
know maybe we probably wear pants and
stuff like that so that you know your
privates are kind of covered up but
still like i would hope so could you
imagine like a little fish just like
getting like under your arms and like
i'm just thinking like a [ __ ] nipple
man
it's like
probably
they'll like sneak in through probably
yeah probably